[Music]
what is this child snow cleaner
[Music]
Jesus Christ holy [ __ ] dude oh can you
buy that
no I mean like is that like a prank like
in some countries that looks like a
child
it's real
yeah
that's [ __ ] up yeah but it's funny
that is pretty funny that kid's gonna
have frostbite on his face
I think he's dead already
[Laughter]
Jesus Christ man what else we got
real life elf on a shelf because this is
just a picture of us sitting down oh
[ __ ] fire everybody in here I'm tired
of gay
Elf on the Shelf what to sit on top of
the kitchen for her holiday party
why is it gay why are you gay why do
they have to discern that
I I mean obviously it's satire but
what's with the pause my mom hired a gay
Elf on a Shelf
you like the voice changer yeah I liked
it at first but I just feel like it's
annoying now I people use it for [ __ ]
that it's like it would just be funny
without it yeah I was I didn't end today
yeah oops got your [ __ ] use that one
yeah
oops got your [ __ ] shake that [ __ ]
I've been uh
really enjoying seeing the uh
yams cover and doing the auto-tune to my
voice wait what yeah this week is that
sweet yeah or whatever there's like
baked an auto tune in no way really and
Tick Tock yeah I went on I went on Tick
Tock for the first time in like two
months yesterday early day before
do you like it and the only I do go on I
don't go on it but Kelsey shows me the
ones that she likes right so I see Tick
Tock through her eyes now nice so I have
it I'm like not up on the trends and
[ __ ] yeah the AI one is funny the like
manga AI [ __ ] yeah that's been funny
now the knuckles so what are the Oddity
let's see it you got a draft I think I
deleted it come on bust out a draft for
us no no no I can't
my voice hurt send me the filter
you don't need it you just can sing it
and then you just touch up the audio
let's see can I get to the ends
sweet jams yeah
[Music]
no no no no no stop that sing it no
what's an old song that I should make a
house remix of
uh uh anything by Abba you think no no
it's probably I was kind of thinking
like old like not that old old is in
like when we were in college
make a house remix of
[ __ ] Malibu Rum by Tech N9ne yeah
okay
151 rum
I was kind of thinking Fergalicious
would be good try it I feel like I think
I'm going to yeah
this is my that's my project for over
the holidays okay I'm making one I'm
gonna spend like two weeks making one
house track and try to make it really
good okay and then I'm gonna come here
and play it all right
first episode in January okay I'm giving
myself that deadline we'll see if we
like it yeah that'll be good yeah yeah
yeah I know I have to make it good
because I know it's gonna like everyone
on the bonus episode is gonna hear it
151 rum
pineapple pineapple pineapple yeah
pineapple pineapple pineapple pineapples
Malibu getting all right
[Music]
someone sent me a Migos meme today I
know it's old but have me laugh and it's
like you get the bag of fumblet I get
the bag and [ __ ] incumbent
laughs
[Laughter]
so stupid I'm just a naked ass dude with
like the money bag emoji like it was
clearly from a porn but you just boning
the [ __ ] out of the bed that's really
good you get the bag I get the big
[ __ ] come in it what's Drake's
engagement ring necklace dude you didn't
see this no it's 42 diamonds and it's a
diamond for each time he thought about
getting married
stupid
is that seriously what he says that's
just so stupid
okay yeah no I'm good what was that I
was just yawning I didn't want to
there's someone back there isn't there
probably now you were just gesturing at
someone I was just you were saying get
back get back yeah yeah that's what it
was
what now I'm on edge can someone please
scare me right now I hope that [ __ ]
uh Nutcracker just Falls forward
that's a [ __ ] Hazard yeah
that you guys should have rigged that
thing up to blow some [ __ ] out
I just
[ __ ] right at the end of the bonus
episode three we're both tired okay guys
uh I guess that's it yeah confetti
everywhere
all right
well hey
everybody thank you for a wonderful year
it's you know this is five years in
this is crazy yeah this is the fifth
Christmas
fifth holiday season yep
and next week's episode you're getting
the highlights of the year yeah it
should be a banger with a little bit of
sauce on it we got a little sauce for
you
and yeah did you sauce that up a little
bit just a little bit
and we um
yeah we got a lot of exciting projects
next year
top of next year will be a little bit
different you know I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be out on the road but
it'll be fine
we got some uh cool guests not at the
top top not the top top now we'll have a
few episodes I'll be fine yeah every
little few little remote moments yeah
remote moments
that's all it is yeah it'll be funny I
like that you said moment like a stylist
yeah yeah it's a little moment yeah
anyways thanks for joining us I gotta
piss so bad thank you guys for
subscribing thank you for subscribing
thanks for a wonderful year I will see
you in the new year we'll see you next
year sorry yeah yeah we do have to take
a second to say and we have to do this
right when you have to pee okay what
we started an app this year yep it's
pretty crazy we did everyone watching
and listening at this point supports the
app we have three shows now
four
on the app yeah yep and we got some we
got some [ __ ] planned yeah we're really
gonna [ __ ] this whole thing up we're
gonna turn podcast on their head
it's like yeah they have a hundred
thousand shows yeah they begin in a
second very fast yeah
yeah
dude
crazy here man
um a lot of hard work yeah thanks to
everyone and big thank you to the team
yes hold that piss I got it and I gotta
like fart and piss at the same time
that's fine
make it hurt big thank you to the crew
you guys rule
we would not be able to achieve any of
this [ __ ] without you guys so big thank
you to you all make our lives
awesome they literally make the app Cody
and I we could we could not do this on
our own at all so yeah
um everyone show the show The Crew Love
and on that note let's play Crew Love by
the weekend
and get out of here
there it is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]